oh there we go am I actually oh my God I
can teleport oh oh hello everybody my
name is markip and welcome back to Five
Nights at Freddy's help wanted I can
move which is wonderful and hey there's
a reason for this camera I knew there
would be and I don't know why I was
recording vertically before but now I'm
not I thought maybe it would make sense
but then I just realized like you it
didn't actually help anything
anyway hey
shiny okay so everything should be fine
there's been an update to the game now
these controllers actually work the way
they're supposed to ooh I'll take
that so what's this hello please do not
touch what am I not supposed to touch
that or am I not supposed to touch that
because if I wasn't supposed to touch
that then you probably should have said
or if I wasn't supposed to H whatever
touching
oh it's a little odd Pig patch
oh okay well that's
terrifying oh
God
uh-huh
that is nice I like that actually but
you you are the most terrifying W of all
these so far in the mini
games oh my
Superstar why do it got to be shadowed
like that can I affect that all right
well
that's that's not UNC creepy hang on let
me establish my
dominance
no now we see well I looked down on you
a little bit now we see eye to now now
we see
now we see eye to eye your perspective
might be different than mine I'm not
going to mess with that anymore okie
dokie
balora why you got to be looking at me I
don't know if that's better let's just
get let's get our boy here yeah that's
better
hello can I help you can you help me I
didn't ask the right question am I
supposed to put some coins
here some over here yes please
okay well now that I'm actually able to
explore the space I don't really know
what to do about everything nothing over
there
whoop there's something there's a
curtain there but the I I peep a little
bit of stage back there through that Gap
it's got to be something that's there
later don't mind if I do why you got to
be
creepy why you got to be creepy stop
being creepy over there I'm not about
that
stop it that plot point in the game was
forgotten you were supposed to be a lot
creepier maybe I is all conjecture but I
I imagine you were supposed to be a lot
creepier I cannot see stop I am your
friend whatever your name was
stop my eyes Okay where was I Lefty this
virus is not doing fizzy Faz Knight yes
lucky you a position recently opened at
the fizzy Faz bottling Warehouse
okay whatever that means I'm here to
have fun that's what it's all about
around here make the correct order and
send it up to the delivery
unit and use the cameras to see if the
staff Bots are working ah the classic
Five Nights at Freddy's experience or I
could just fall
asleep oh
god well this is more detailed than I
was
hoping
you are here oh my God holy
sign form start work uh-huh yeah
hold on let me get my bearings is there
a coin under here sign form start work
you got a coin under there sign form
start work yeah okay all right you're
not really very file signature
accepted new job instruction use
container collect necessary ingredients
make fizy flavor syrup convenience order
display shows necessary ingredients
uh-huh yeah you got
it sugar
sugar place in delivery unit that got to
be there what I do go if er a mistake
press trash button don't bad ingredients
campaign this is both a waste of company
time and money warned dumping
ingredients May attract unwanted
pests uh-huh wait what was that going on
there okay you're doing a thing you're
doing a thing you're doing a thing what
is going on here
oh yeah your tablet's not even
on whatever uh this
looks okay all right interest
oh
uh-huh interesting okay you're doing
something you're doing something you're
doing something you better watch
it that's broken that's broken um I
imagine I'm supposed to be doing some
but hold on let me dump that Sugar
caffeine caffeine okay I'm going to have
a little tough time getting okay did I
need to do that in order I don't even
know I but I
hey a why why
why there was no need to do a jump scare
you could have just fired
me was that necessary was any of that
necessary is any of this necessary I was
getting my bearings just let me get my
bearings if you can let me if you start
me in the right I guess actually just
makes
sense you not like now oh all right
whatever what are you doing what are you
doing H sugar caffeine
okay
okay wait hey what's what do you mean
what do you mean what do you mean what
do you mean what do you mean what do you
mean there we go all
right that was pretty good okay who's
doing work what's going on there all
right caffeine acid acid okay
carefully okay
wham wham all right you working you
working you oh my
God all right sugar acid
acid wait Sugar Sugar
acid you got it oh there you
go what are you doing what are you doing
what are you doing what are you doing
what are you
doing sugar caffeine acid
okay Wham boom record
time hey hey hey hey what's up pal all
right caffeine acid acid this is
easy Wham
won I'm assuming I actually have to pay
attention to these cameras returned and
work same time tomorrow thank
you I'm I did
it yep y yep
yippe
yippe oh
excellent that's
great that's
great
yippee
woohoo W boy
wow I don't want to go there sister
location is a little bit spooky these
other ones are fun kind
of uh you know since I'm in the mode of
uh of doing this I'm just going to keep
doing this if staff Bots
breaks occasionally or you may regret
what do you mean where shut down if
things get out of hand what they're
they're
unionizing in my capitalist
Dreamland I won't have it I won't have
it you are back may become bosle why
Force breaks if staff strike use shut
down button for three boot no no you you
you you you start
working
work we need to get oh I I got to do
protein I'm not going to hit anything
why protein this this who's who's doing
it who's doing it okay whatever caffeine
acid protein you guys got to hurry up
the protein delivery needs to happen how
do I whoa okay you take a break my dude
oh my God I did not like that hey what's
up pal hey I whatever oh
oh oh it's obvious now okay okay lemon
can take a break take a break
lemon yep you take a break sugar oh you
don't look so good you maybe I don't
know what's wrong with them you you take
a break I guesso all right caffeine man
all right caffeine you got to uh you got
to step it up man caffeine man can you
go go go go can we please caffeine no no
you go you
get what are wrong with you this isn't
right God damn
it you you're screwing me you're what's
what e what's going on there okay
whatever I'm going to get rid of
that uh I probably could reuse some of
that but whatever protein lots of
protein that's good lemon how are you
not just take a break give me caffeine
lemon take a break candy take a break
lemon take a break oh God give me give
me caffeine I'm going to take a break
okay come on F me give me a
f give me a oh you o give me a
f were you
stressed well thank you God
fan you
fy
bastard can you work
faster this is
horrifying this is not what I
need not what I need okay we're fine on
Candy you you've been taking too many
breaks honestly I'm not going to I'm not
even I can
make there yeah oh get in get in h you
yes all right you take a break all right
what do we got we got plenty of protein
protein man take a break it it'll come
don't worry don't worry
protein
caffeine
shoot what are you doing caffeine
man give me what are you
doing what is wrong with you work faster
work okay well one more sugar and then
Happy Bonk okay listen listen caffeine
guy you got to go you you you got to
go I get it caffeine's in high demand
for some reason got to get the charged
lemonades all that whatever can you get
one more one would be so good right now
let see you take a break there you go
or not what is wrong with
you all right well shoot I'm
about CA caffeine man protein acid
caffeine and sugar okay bam okay we're
off Off to the Races okay you take a
break
hello okay two proteins okay acid
caffeine and as soon as protein man is
up off his break we're good to
go protein
man protein
man got it okay you take a break I
should done caffeine caffeine's now not
slacking uh
right protein one of each
okay all right who needs it coffee break
you got it yeah you got plenty of coffee
lemon you're up next on the
break double protein okay protein man
you can't take a break just
yet okay caffeine acid protein please
protein man hurry up you're in demand
today I know I know you need a break I'm
just going to give it to him I know I
know it's not time cuz it's not going to
be protein fck
all we're going to miss this one that's
okay we're just going to build up for
the next one because I know we're going
to miss this but we can take one and
this will give us what we need then
Sugar's going to take a break bam okay
then coffee's going to take a break oh
sugar wants a break no they have a break
okay then I'm going we're going to miss
it it's okay I'm not even going to try
cuz it waste hello stop that we're just
going to let protein it'll build up
that's fine we can take one it's fine
right
okay it's fine okay exactly what we need
exactly what we
need this really is a charged lemonade
except without the acid okay protein man
you can't take a break yet sorry just
can't happen can't have it got to get
those protein levels up let it's taking
a break candy will be after that see
this is what I mean protein this is what
I mean asci in Sugar done okay I'm going
to wait a bit cuz we can take that break
cuz the sooner I do the next one okay
now protein can take a break I'm going
to wait a little bit on that because
rushing it out the door doesn't help
anybody and you take a
break then you go we're doing great
we're doing so good you take a break
next yep return and work yes same time
tomorrow that's what I'm talking about
capitalism baby give me my
reward okay
oh
hey hey look at you okay I thought that
was a
surprise do I got a discount ball
pit where is
it where is
it where is it oh do I get the model of
it discount ball
pit discount ball
pit
what are you for I don't have a Faz
wrench got that all right by hey
hey but I I did so much
training I did so much training for that
I got really get fine going to the
private room oh
freak that H
shoot
surv everything El is like yeah make a
soda yeah play a carnival game don't
die oh wouldn't be Five Nights at
Freddy's without it close the office
down if you feel if you feel threatened
be careful not to run out of
power a true experience which is strange
because everyone criticized sister
location for not being like the others
now we got the truest experience out of
it shows you guys that's why F sister
that's why Fister location you should
stay away but sister location great
don't worry about a
thing oh Freak
Me can I even reach those okay reach
that uh that's kind of in the wall but I
think I can reach it okay so how to I
event o lock is that a hammer have I got
a
hammer hold on everybody I'm looking for
hammer all right whatever
oh oh that's going to be difficult to
see but that's okay Mark what did that
say pause on that put the code up on
screen get markers on it we're watching
and never mind I figured it out
sorry sorry it's okay okay so so what
what's going
on what's the deal with
that what's what's the
deal what's going on why is that one
okay we're oh my God not
today what is that
that one okay
185 that's not
bad am I actually okay did I do that too
early I feel like I might
o ooh
what oh my God what's happening what's
happening what was that did I get it did
I
survive five nights set
Freddy's oh that's interesting okay so
that's fine
vent no one in the vent one up there o
that one's dead that's not good okay
checking checking oh that's not good
either okay oh oh
oh okay that's
okay so that's a little early on that I
could wait a little longer but I don't
want
to yesh okay I don't know if you guys
can see the screens as well as oh my
God
good I think yes very
good okay so it just seems to be entered
there's no one else having fun how do I
know if you're going up there she this
is this is like the VR experience I want
out of Five Nights at Freddy's this is
what I want oh hi okay so what does that
do for me nothing we're all good
probably like you're coming down this
hallway no
no where'd you go where'd you go oh hey
what's up bud let me make sure no one
else is sneaking up on
me yep all right cool you're there okay
I'm going to give it five four 3 two I
panicked I tried to catch him off guard
that's what I did
[Music]
there yep I hear you I'm just going to I
I don't trust opening that before the
sounds are done oh God what do you
mean wait what do you
mean what do you
mean well this is going poorly cuz I
don't even know which way I'm supposed
to be right now yeah freck good good all
good all good okay
mhm
great great good o uh
that's well I got that just in time um
just going to leave that close for a bit
I wonder if I can do I see him coming do
I have time to like react should I test
it probably
not okay oo 2 a.m. I'm going to test it
this time because if if this is actual
3D space then I should see him coming
around the
corner right otherwise it' just be kind
of
right okay this is awful I'm
I'm going to do it I'm going
to okay he's right there hey bud what's
up what's up pal what's up try me come
on what you what are you going to do
what are you going to do you going to
come at me
oh oh my
[Music]
god oh I get it so I had actually plenty
of time good good great oh are we
lagging well that's strange okay I'm
going to okay all right that's fine
don't know why that was lagging but it
don't matter I'm
amazing okay oh hi
that's well I'm
uncomfortable what are you doing down
there what are you doing uh-huh okay all
right I'm going to I'm there's time and
there's no one else coming right good
and there's that big audio queue that's
like hey look out okay oh oh good well I
got plenty of temp well that's that's
all the time in the
world okay well if that's fine then I
thought I needed to
worry
uhhuh
uh-huh aha pole dancing are you oh
that's okay I don't mind it's
respectable enough got to pay the
bills where you going are you going you
you in the oo okay so this is fine
hey hello hello hello hello how are you
hello are you how are you I asked you
first I asked you first I asked you
first I first oh that's really mature
saying exactly what I'm saying what I'm
saying
I'm I'm an
idiot you're an idiot I
got you're an idiot you're an idiot
you're an idiot Why didn't it push the
button I was
there I was right there on the play and
it it didn't do
it it just didn't do it all right
whatever so at least I can keep an eye I
bet there's another night of this with
more monsters at least there should be
if there's not that's a bit of a Miss
hello hi what's up cutie do you have a
hammer I really want to get this thing
open I don't see see any drawers that I
can
wonk there's nothing
wonk can I move no moving is not not
good okay you in this room uhhuh I see
you so ah so I can press the
buttons I just didn't for some reason
maybe I pressed the grippies and didn't
let me okay I'm ready for you come on oh
he comes down the vent quick comes out
really fast but this
one little more leisurely I see
you I smell you
anyway oh slow slow ha
haa okay
cheater thank you okay 2:
a.m. can you at least like thk on the
door when you're you're done just like
wonk on it a few times that'd be really
nice all right okay should be
fine all right where are you you back
there
you
sassy you want to try something
different it's like when you're playing
rock paper scissors just so paper so
that's all you are just a big
nothing big flimsy flapping in the wind
nothing
me guess you're going to show back up
here
again mayhaps is this gravable it
is fascinating let
me yeah
uh-huh where are
you yeah I bet yeah I bet okay all right
just take your time there got to be
something with that trash it's the only
thing that I can interact with oh hello
yum oh oh God where'd he go oh okay all
right come on I'm on down don't be
shy come
on I'm very
friendly to some
people
uh-huh
yeah okay all right sure yeah sure
thing idiot comes charging down the
hallway I meant to time that better it
would have been much more insulting if
it actually lined
up uh can you edit that to line it up a
bit better that'd be thank you thank you
for making me look so
cool that's what I look like right
cool all right yoink yoink yink okay
uhhuh there he
is damn you ugly you know if you try a
different door maybe you'd have some
success not today hey is that a switch I
can flip God the
Wall come on down uh idiot comes
charging down the
hallway damn whoa wait whoa what what
what do you mean what do you what do you
mean what can he do
that whoa wait a minute whoa wait a
minute what how what do you mean what do
you mean what did you just do don't make
a fool out of
me don't do
it oh fascinating
how'd you do
that how did you do that oh
God okay all right come on I'm ready for
you do it do it do it do it I'm an
idiot I'm an
idiot you're an
idiot
[Music]
boom wait a minute I I know about
enjoying some time at home it usually
doesn't go too well for
the the homely
enjoyer okay I hope it's
entered
yeah can't wait to see him with my
eyes you're not even letting me do
anything something to change anything
change
change anything change Enard you there
no not you the okay not now what I was
looking
for I don't know if this is a good idea
to just have you here cuz I feel like
this is kind of um giving you an
opportunity to murder me don't
move don't
change I hope you
don't yeah you stay there
okay anyway that's it for this episode
thank you everybody so much for watching
you had a wonderful time more Five
Nights at Freddy's coming soon now that
they actually updated and I can move
that means I can finish it so I will
more Five Nights at Freddy's in the
description more scary games check out
distractable and all the other good
stuff thank you and as always I will see
you in the next video
bye-bye